vince changed
us from two good guys
and and and he changed their names to
the bushwackers because he wanted to own
us
he didn't like the sheep oh because he
wanted to change it so he could own it
he could yeah
he didn't want us he didn't he wanted us
to be um
the good guys he says you know it's time
for you to change to be the good guys
we'd been the bad guys i had been a bad
guy from
1962 to 1988. what's with the whole
sheep gimmick
what what what is because new zealand
has got 3 million people
and 100 million sheep
that's what i said did you catch on
before when i said
the sheep shaggers no i i heard that i
heard that i don't know where it came
from new zealand's well known for that
there's really over a hundred million
sheep
new zealanders evergreen mate they burnt
all the
the um rough um gorse
and all the the the pla weed and all
that
and they um
they they put grazing they grasp seeded
the whole
the whole countryside of the hills and
everything
we were the first country to do top
dressing on planes you know when they
they they drop the seeds out of the
wings and they're coming over the
pastures and that yeah yeah
they were the first country to do that
and the whole country's
mountainous like that yeah they've got
big mountains but
we're just covered in sheep you know
sheep were everywhere did you have any
bad sheep
did you have your own sheep no no i
didn't
i was a but the sheep farms you know the
the sheep farms
in new zealand they they're they're
three or four miles
you know some of them are two or three
miles by three miles really yeah that's
a big
big farms a hundred million shoes that
must be a big
experiment and yet it was until
synthetic came in
we were big and big and farm products
you know
they are butter and and our wool but now
everything's synthetic
that's that that killed our uh economy
when it was
when that synthetic stuff come out
synthetic wool and all that they started
doing all that stuff
but new zealand was big export and wool
so for your gimmick you guys were called
the sheep herders
and we used to come out in sheep jackets
too you know white jackets
with the sleeves off thick wool thick
wool like that
did you guys ever bring a sheep with you
no like to walk out with a sheep
you can't bring a sheep into a wwe match
i mean stone cold brought out a giant
[ __ ] beer truck
she put his inmates we were the we were
the bushwhackers no i'm talking about
when you were the sheepherder no we
yeah we we never had sheep we just
carried the new zealand flag
we were known for being nasty son of a
[ __ ]
if you go online that says the the sheep
earners were hardcore
before hardcore became our name brand
why so what did you guys do that was so
nasty
the way we worked and we were blood and
guts just roughed them up
rough them up blood and gas you know a
lot all of our
that's why we worked a lot in south
america and a lot of
you know in the territories where was
the black where they had bloody matches
all the time
we would have and we came up with a lot
of different matches
that um we are the names of a lot of
different matches
those days there were territories mate
when we come over here
everywhere you were around seven nights
a week even when we went into that
grand prix and that they ran seven towns
they were running 21 towns a week you
know what i mean
and that is every night and you come
back to you do programs
with guys you might see roddy piper
butch and me worked
with rick martin and roddy piper for a
year
every night where you could be going to
six man's
they'd bring in um jessie ventura or
they bring in the
the giant and we're bringing another guy
to be an outsider
and we just worked with those two the
town so you can have story lines and
and plan things and do things you to
spike it and all and then you'd sell out
then you'd go down to three quarters of
the house
and it'll start winning then you spike
it again and come up you know what i
mean
that's what you have television for to
do angles um
to set you up to plots yeah yeah and
that's when the hill does stuff to get
to get the people going that's where
vince is like
at the moment because being a being
a public company and he's got all these
stockholders and that he can't do heavy
stuff like he did before
so when vince bought you when vince when
asked us to come in there so what was
that like what was that like did you
meet him did he reach out to you what
was that
we were we were working with turner at
the time yeah and that
and we were working to get the main guys
there
and um was it we were working cincinnati
on a saturday night i'd always remember
this and i'm in the goals gym with butch
in the morning and um i never worked my
drum out so much
butch always worked his drum at the end
of a workout his drum the drum your
stomach
your drum oh your drum okay i never
heard that i like that
working my drum man you got to fill your
drama that's why you go to a restaurant
that's right
i love that or your boiler my [ __ ]
drum mate
you put your
to pick up my messages from my home i
was living in charlotte
yeah because that's where they that's
where that was the headquarters for nwa
and that they were all running all over
the country
as far as as far as baltimore and philly
and we would go to long island now and
again
but we never went into into manhattan or
any of there or up on
up the east coast there wwe
wwe wwwf
was up there that was vince's vince
senior
ted turner's television was never strong
the his
thing wasn't in the program in the
packages of the cable
you know tbs wasn't strong up there to
i'd say 90
88 90 tbs got stronger in the northern
parts
and it's strong everywhere now you know
what i mean that's 30 years ago
but um usa network
and wc is it wn
what's the another cables a few cables
they're strong up there anyhow
so we wouldn't come up that far and i
anyhow they went to the
anyhow going back to cincinnati went and
pulled up my messages and there's a
voice
it's pat here he says when you've got
time give give me a call
pat patterson yes wow oh you know pat
i know pat patterson yeah yeah pat
patricia
anyhow um one of the one of the best tag
wrestlers
ever now he's like one of the top
executives right at wwe yeah
yeah but one of the top you know he was
one of the top human race demons
the butcher me copied there a lot a bit
of their stuff too
they were the best tag teams ever anyhow
he said give us a call
so i said that's funny so now i give it
a
i give the now got a call and i'm on
speakerphone
and uh the speakerphone there in vince's
vince's home not in the office there in
his home and i said
pat then he's here pat he says uh yeah
there's a guy here wants to talk to you
and then then the voice in the
background says
kiwi
i'd like to use you i said who are you
saying i vince mcmahon here and i i've
been sending tapes to this [ __ ]
bastard
so since betamax if you know what
betamax is
yeah early 80
yeah i've been selling to the dad the
betamax
and then i said and i can every year i
send tapes to them
can you use this because that was the
number one
um one of the number one
companies in the country you know i mean
right then he worked up north at the
time
they only came down as far as
philadelphia and baltimore
and they did boston and they did all
that up there but it was big money there
so i've been trying a bit anyways they
didn't take us smaller guys
at the time they they had big guys i'm
talking about
guys six foot four six foot three
and 260 up you know
so he said he says yeah and i said yeah
and i said yes i mentioned i'm
interested he says
when can i see see ya when can i talk to
you
and i says you just named the time
and that no and we were working planned
every day
and um for nwa and he says right when
you get home
there'll be tickets at your door at your
door
there'll be tickets at your door when
you get home i gave him my address
on the phone and um he says next
wednesday
so and he said all you do you don't have
to bring anything with
you when you fly out there you'll be
flying home the same night
so we flew into um kennedy
there was a limousine up there waiting
for us
we have straight up to stanford
connecticut which is an hour away
from kennedy met vince
vince jr vince jr yeah senior was dead
okay senior died in in four
three or four eighty-three four and then
we met she
met him and that funny part of us went
into the office set
and was sitting there and he says to us
you know i'd like to
bring you in his baby faces good guys
and of course i
i piped up and said to him bring us in
his heels first
and turn us and he says no i don't do
things that way.
and then i then i found out you don't
tell caesar his nickname was caesar
you don't tell jew caesar what to do you
know what i mean yeah
he says that that and i'd like you to be
between
the sheepherders and the moon dogs
work like between the sheepherders and
the moon dog the moon dogs were two guys
and had bones big heavy guys were crazy
and had bones you know what i mean and
there were heels up there
and then he says and i'll start bringing
you up every week
for the next month to do vignettes which
you know what vignettes are
small movies two to three minute movies
you know to get you over
so um we we got home
and when we got home and that there was
the tickets there two days later
butch calls me up and he says [ __ ]
there's something here
a package here they've sent the wrong
names it's for the
for the bushwhackers and i says the
butch
he says they must have sent them to the
wrong person i said no
he's changing our name because he wants
to own it you know what i mean
he's changing their name okay so that's
that's how we became
the um the bushwackers